2 peu à peu au fur et à mesure que
l'accalmie semble s'étendre ce que nous
confirmait patricia le nouveau pouvoir
se met en place sa figure de proue
semble être violent
iliescu qui fut il ya plus de 15 ans
secrétaire du comité central du pc room
alors qui sont ces hommes nouveaux
michel mon compte et le nouveau pouvoir
politique roumain c'est d'abord un lieu
celui de sa naissance
le studio 4 de la télévision à bucarest
ces deux-là coeur par heure ce nouveau
pouvoir a structuré motivés et surtout
organiser la révolte
le conseil du front de salut national à
39 membres un mélange fait anciens
communistes et d'intégrer d'ici l'an
dans le premier cas y en liesse qui
sommes populaires et dynamique de 59 ans
est pourtant un ancien haut
fonctionnaire de chercher ce coup mais
huit ans de disgrâce loin de pouvoir
l'ont rachetée au jeu des roumains il
est apparu au premier rang du comité de
salut dès vendredi matin annonçant la
fuite chercher ce coup l'autre homme
fort de ce conseil ces cornées nolwenn
et ce coup l'ancien représentant de la
roumanie à l'onu lui aussi ancien
communiste passé par la disgrâce mais on
le dit malade il a disparu du devant de
la scène depuis vendredi dernier
l'autre face de ce conseil ait fait
d'intellectuels et de dissidents comme
laszlo tokes 37 ans un pasteur romain
qui est à l'origine des émeutes de
timisoara et n'opposant courageux du
temps de la toute-puissance les chercher
ce coup dont il n'a cornet a bien sûr
est dans le même cas chercher ce coup
n'aura jamais réussi malgré toutes ses
tentatives et ses menaces à faire taire
la voix de la plus célèbre dissidente du
pays
enfin sergiu nicolaescu surnommé l'
alain delon du cinéma roumain depuis
trois jours on le dit partout au combat
dans les rues il est la caution
populaire du conseil du fonds de salut
national
il fut le premier visage à paraître
vendredi
sur le petit écran de la télévision
roumaine ebr